right we're going to get cranking down
most of this question is fairly
straightforward but there is this one
bit that a lot of people just sort of
lift in it sideways and fair enough it's
one of those questions where these are
these don't really the important
questions I've talked about this before
then you can sort of go one two three on
stage really carefully without deeply
understanding what's going on but just
going through steps and we've done these
three times that you recognize the
patterns but where you get to plus C
that pushes on deep can you be
thoughtful about this and not just like
go through the just go through your
step-by-step algorithm right so first
let's get the easy parts out of the way
and then we will and then we'll tackle
the acoustic club okay so there's your
equation one point central squared times
e to the negative x and to play the
intercepts will there be X intercepts
the y intercept right let's give this a
crack how do I find the x intercepts
wipin 0 so I'm gonna send out like this
for X y 0 which means y equals 0 so this
thing equal 0 right
in other words 1 plus X now why not here
certainly not the most important thing
about a question but it's worth saying
at this point here I think it's kind of
pain you're saying like you've got two
factors you well we kind of have three
right you've got what must Xu comma plus
expert again and then you've got meeting
the negative x now I'm about to ignore
the e to the negative x in a second I'm
going to treat it as not currently
question the reason why is because it
doesn't contribute anything it can never
contribute anything to solving this
equation why is that point very good
even the negative x right we know what
this looks like this is the exit just
call it off so e to the negative X is
different in that it's flipped
horizontally
is on the eggs from my morning so it's
coming down like this asymptotic to the
x-axis but it never actually collides so
I'm going to say at this point but even
though you live X is never equal to 0 at
least your real values so therefore I
can just say look this is what I'm
interested in this is the part that's
actually going to give me some solutions
okay so are you with me so far
yep take a look okay excellent so now I
have an x intercept no problem I'm going
to save you the times I think you know
what to do here for the y intercept let
X equal zero are you going to get for a
memory y equals one you pop that it you
know look at that one plus zero squared
times e to the 0 which is 1
it's a little example okay so that's
fine let's go about 20 points so what do
I need to find 10 points I needed to
hear it don't I know it is so I'll use
plural I kind of am going to use chain
rule because I don't want to have to
expand that so it's a simple version on
the back so the derivative the first
derivative which is probably all might
be I'm gonna read off I'm gonna read up
product rule just in here with you gonna
be right so I'm gonna go be that's you -
two times good morning sometimes you're
don't want appreciate you so anyway I
can be you -
well I tend to go alphabetical we like
with various or product rule it doesn't
matter which ones which
right but it just makes sense to call
the first thing you say it's getting two
times okay maybe you - review is just we
just and one was and now we get to be -
which is negative into the you guys
happy
okay now where am I going with this
what am I trying to find out it is
derivative the Android software so I
might as well therefore factorize as far
as I possibly can because factorizing
like this is what makes it easy to solve
right what can I take out of this okay I
could take out I could take out a video
so here I suppose but B but it's on the
second turnover I think I'm just gonna
leave you I'm just gonna leave a bit
other will take out the e to the
negative X what else can I say
yeah the oneplus X let's just like a
front be back in there okay what am I
left with
- that's - site comes along for the ride
and there's our one post X in there I
mean I took out one of them this this -
so 1 + X isn't it happy so now I can
factorize a little more fully and it
looks to me like that's worth takeaway X
yes okay now remembering that this is
actually not a particle question that
we're focusing on I think you can see
here I'm going to get the to tow you
points for the same reason that I didn't
get a solution from this before that I'm
gonna have x equals 1 and negative 1
right
okay now the exact wording of the
question says sure the kerb has two
turning points and classify them so I
don't actually need to find their
y-coordinates I mean I mean I can it's
not difficult but that's not the
question is not asking for a vacation of
these things I've shown there's two
places where there are stationary words
so what I need to do from there yes I
have a couple of choices I can use the
first derivative and do a table values
or I could do the second derivative and
then I can just test at those points
which are you profess so this is I could
write this in this way I could I could
do I could do that honestly honestly I
kind of feel like this is really on the
line like I think and to be honest I'm
just really quickly show you in a pH I
did I did attend values and it's really
it's really not that complicated okay
but it's true like this is about the
same good morning is that the same ish
difficulty of differentiating this right
so it's not that complicated okay now
whichever way you'd go about it and
again because not the focus and
something you guys have dealt with mid
times whether you go back first
derivative or second derivative I
believe you'll find let's see x equals
negative one pretty sure is a bit of a
which makes this guy at home that's okay
so obviously that takes a bit of time to
establish them do either path and how it
will pop yourself